je pense qu'on ne veut pas poursuivre
les parents
c'est une caricature que de dire cela
ainsi j'ai d'ailleurs dit moi-même que
n'était pas question à mon avis de
supprimer des allocations je pense en
particulier je pense en particulier aux
femmes qui travaillent qui sont seuls
qui élèvent leur famille
qui le font avec beaucoup de dignité
dans la difficulté je pense aussi à des
parents qui pourraient faire un certain
nombre de choses vis-à-vis de leurs
enfants en particulier assuré l'autorité
parentale et qui ne le font pas vous
voyez dans ces nuits courtes que nous
avons eu les uns et les autres émaillés
de mauvaises nouvelles et de vidéos il y
a une vidéo qui m'a plu c'est celle du
père qui va récupérer son gamin par le
callback et qu'ils iront à la maison
parce qu'il y a 11 ans traîne pas dans
les rues je veux rappeler d'ailleurs que
nous avons tous nos souvenirs enfin pour
ceux qui se sont mariés des dispositions
de l'articles 212 du Code civil les
époux se doivent mutuellement fidélité
ce courrier assistance on oublie le
reste les parents ont une obligation
morale ça n'est pas plus compliqué que
ça à l'égard de leurs enfants oui et
ceux qui peuvent et qui ne le font pas
méritent d'être sanctionnés puis il y a
une responsabilité civile qui est très
simple c'est quand les enfants cassent
bah c'est les parents qui payent ça
existe depuis toujours et il faut le
rappeler enfin il y a une autre
responsabilité pénale qui consiste que
l'enfant est convoqué pour les parents
de l'accompagner devant la justice et
s'il ne le fait pas il encore une amende
qui est une amende importante j'ai
rappelé ça j'ai demandé au procureur de
le mettre en oeuvre je viens à
l'attention des parents de rédiger un
flyer voilà c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça qui explique en terme simple quels
sont les obligations pour les parents
madame la sénatrice qu'il aurait oublié
[Musique]